- Okay, big bite. Ahh
- You like?
- It is so good!
Oh my gosh.
- It's super sweet.
- Oh my gosh.
So I understand that you actually have
special voices for all your pets.
So can you show us some of your voices?
- Well, my Turkey voice,
(turkey sound)
- so it's basically Thanksgiving.
So do the holidays.
Are they crazy for y'all?
Or do your families get
together? You love it?
- Love it, love it, love.
- Yeah.
- She's like, she's a real whatever.
Like holiday maven.
- Yeah, I'm a holiday maven.
I enjoy the holidays. I lean in.
- I- I do too, 'cause it's off time.
- Yeah. I did, yeah and
I did Martha Stewart
'cause I love her. Not
because I, you know,
actually made fun of
her. I wanted to be her.
- But she's the closest thing
to Martha Stewart, that I know.
- Amazing. Your impression is amazing.
- Oh, thank you!
- Do you-
- That's hilarious.
- Do you just break out- Please say at
Holidays you just break
out in this character.
- I go, I go full in. Either spreadsheets,
and yeah.
- Oh my
God.
- Yeah.
- What are your family
like, any traditions?
- We go to Vermont every year,
which is really beautiful,
because I have relatives up
there- but, well the only
the one holiday that went
badly was the next day
at around like two in the
morning I started vomiting
and then I found out that
everyone there had food poisoning.
So like the whole family had food poison.
- Who cooked?
- But we all found out later.
- Who did cook?
- Um, I don't quite remember.
- You don't wanna sell anyone out?
- Bu-but, I just, it might
have had to do with like the stuffing.
I don't know.
- Yeah, it's a cautionary stuffing tale.
- It's a cautionary stuffing tale.
Anyway, that's not a fun story but.
- A public service
announcement from Rachel.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. That's, Be careful.
- It's important. Take
the stuffing out separate.
Just do it separate.
- Take care of yourself.
Maybe cook your food fully.
- But usual- Usually it's fun.
- Yeah, usually when you're not
having food poisoning.
- My family has had a broken refrigerator,
oven, disposal, I've had
every major appliance break
on Thanksgiving.
- Wow.
- So I, I'm, yeah.
Anyway, it's a great way to
get to know your neighbors.
- So wait, what do you have for us today?
This is beautiful.
- So as you know
we often start eating with
our eyes before our mouths.
So a really important thing
around the holidays is to
make a beautiful table-scape.
So I'm gonna show you how to
put one together on the cheap.
- Okay. Okay.
What do we do first? What's first?
- So first thing obviously
start from the bottom.
- Yeah.
- So what I like to do
is, for a tablecloth
the tablecloths can be expensive.
- Yeah.
- Needlessly. I like to go to Goodwill
or to any big store and
just get a cheap sheet.
- Okay, we have little sheets.
- You can get a nice flat sheet
for sometimes under 10 bucks.
- Okay.
- So you get a teap-cheap
sheet, a teap tea
- A teap cheet
- A cheap sheet, or a cheat
sheet, and you just tear it.
And then you can also make
napkins out of it as well.
- Oh, you're tearing
it making napkins? Oh!
- Yes, because napkins
are expensive as well.
- Okay.
- A whole matching set,
with just a bed sheet.
- A whole matching set. And so you just-
- Okay, I just love ripping things!
- And the great thing is
people are always like, oh
they're gonna be all wonky.
No, they go right along the seam.
- They do the seam. Wow!
- And you've got a perfect little napkin.
- I love that
- Right there.
- There's something
sexy about ripping this.
- Ohhh
- Yeah. It's like- Ayee
- Another body roll.
- It does, it's kind- Another body roll.
And also, mental health
wise- It feels good!
- Yeah!
- It's like popping the
whole plastic bubble.
- Yeah. I'm like, I got to rip something.
Okay, What's next after this?
- I have a memorable Thanksgiving story.
It seems like we're pretty
close to the holiday, so-
- Did yo- did you ever see your mom
- just lose it?
(Laughter)
You know, the first time
it was nine years old
and my mom was in Scotland.
A very, very strict woman, very stoic.
No Jamie, you sit still,
you be quiet, all that
kind of thing you know?
And my mom married my dad,
who was an Italian guy.
And when you're Italian,
every meal is huge,
especially Thanksgiving.
You know, my mother went
through three ovens in 12 years.
Literally. Literally burned
them out, just cooking meals.
Oka- Okay,
So she's getting ready
for Thanksgiving you know,
up at 5:30 basting the
turkey and candied yams
and making the stuff-
the stuffing and lasagna.
My mom would make her own pasta
and then cut it, you know?
Cause when you're Italian
you're taught the pilgrims
brought lasagna. Turkey was a side there.
I mean, it's, yeah- Okay.
So anyway, so my mom was
cooking all this, you know
and we would always have
dinner about one o'clock, 1:30
in the afternoon. So, okay,
so the relatives are all, I put the leaf
in the table, you know, make it bigger.
And we're all sitting around
and my dad's sitting there
and my mom comes in carrying
this 21 pound Turkey
and a big sweat stains under arms.
And she puts the turkey in front of my dad
and she give my- she gives
my dad the electric knife.
You remember those stupid things?
Okay., So my dad takes the
electric knife and goes,
click, click. And he goes,
"it's not plugged in.
Do I have to do everything in this house?"
Well, that was the wrong thing to say.
I had no idea turkeys could fly.
Literally, across the room.
Oh my. Oh, I, I, I just saw
My mom went crazy and we just ate lasagna
because the turkey was
over there in the corner.
- All right y'all,
Thanksgiving is almost here
which means one thing and one thing only
PIES! I love pie.
Today I am joined by the founder
of Sweet Lady Jane Bakery,
which is awesome.
This is Jane Lockhart y'all
who brought us some incredible pies today.
And I'm gonna rank them from
my favorite to least favorite
which in reality there will
not be a least favorite
because it's a pie.
- I think we should
start with the apple pie.
- Okay, let's do it.
Oh my God, I love your size of pie.
- Oh, I just love apple pies.
So that's why I put them on first.
- Um, okay. Big bite, Ah
- You like?
- It is so good.
I just wanna make sure I like it.
- So this one is our southern pecan.
It's got a little bourbon inside.
I hope that's okay with you.
- Oh my God, I love bourbon.
- And I think you'll be
able to taste it too.
- You make these awesome desserts.
Like, do you just not
eat them all the time?
- I take two or three bites.
- Oh, that's- me too.
- And everybody makes fun of me.
- Oh my gosh!
- For, for special occasions. But-
- This is amazing and it's the best- and
I'm not lying, the best
pecan pie I've ever had.
- Thank you! That's a great compliment.
- Do you say peh-khan or peh-kan?
Or pee-kan, they say
pee-kan where I'm from.
I say peh-khan.
- I say peh-khan
- Yeah, me too.
- Yeah, I had to think
about that for a second.
- I think we're right.
- One of our newer pies.
- Oh my gosh
I'm getting that crust,
it's gonna be mine.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, let me make room.
- Okay, this is our mixed berry.
- Oh my gosh!
- It's super sweet.
- Your husband is the
luckiest man on the planet.
Now we have saved
what generally is my
favorite pie for last.
- So you like a lot or a little or-
- I'm a Texan, so you go ahead and guess.
- Right on top there.
- This is my favorite.
- Is it?
- It's because, here's the thing.
Oh my gosh, I can taste the- that is good!
Okay, I love all the pies.
- Final rating?
- Final ratings are-
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I don't know which one.
And I'm always the pumpkin pie person,
but it's either the pumpkin
or the pecan or my favorite.
And then these all tied
for like right behind it.
You guys, there's no,
you're putting like the most
heavenly desserts in front of me.
You wanted me to rank them.
Are you insane?
I'm not being nice.
I would just be like,
oh, this one is okay.
Like, no, they're all amazing.
I love you.
I'm gonna take this from you
and I'm gonna give you a
hug after I hand this off.
Hold that pumpkin pie plate near.
Don't take it, Jane.
Seriously? I mean, this is
the best dessert, y'all.
- Thank you.
- I'm not kidding.
I'm not getting paid by her.
I'm saying I love this pie.
All right y'all-
- All right, thank you.
- Enjoy some pies or don't if you're dumb.
Okay.